les Chéries on va revenir sur cette
affaire on va recevoir Lila victime d'un
cambriolage durant lequel ont été volé
les médailles de guerre de son mari
décédé ancien combattant et résistant sa
femme lance un cri de cœur ce soir pour
retrouver les 27 médailles volées euh
voilà elle est elle a beaucoup de peine
Lila on a décidé de la recevoir ce soir
vous allez voir son histoire est folle
et on se dit si ça peut aboutir voilà à
ce que les médailles soient rendues
retrouver ce serait vraiment très très
bien pour elle parce que c'était son
dernier souvenir vous allez voir elle
est extrêmement ému ce soir il a
regardez alors que les cambriolages
semblent se multiplier ces derniers
temps ces cambriolages en série qui ont
touché des domiciles une retraitée qui
vit dans le loté Garon a à son tour été
victime d'un vol par effraction à son
domicile durant son absence mais les
voleurs ne sont pas repartis avec des
produits de luxe mais avec 27 médailles
et des décorations qui ont appartenu à
son défunt mari combattant de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale des objets qui ont une
valeur hautement symbolique pour Lila
qui est aujourd'hui dévasté ce que
j'aimerais qui se rendent et qu' me
rendent ses médailles le cri du cœur de
Lila ce soir dans
tespmp merci Lila d'être avec nous veuve
de Francis et victime d'un
cambriillolage merci d'être là Lila
merci merci de m'avoir invité bah c'est
normal j'espère que ça va abouir à
quelque chose ça me touche bah j'espère
qu'on va aboutir à un résultat d là êtes
extrêmement élégante en tout cas vous
êtes très joli ouais très belle ah je
vous le dis je crois que nous avons la
même on avé pareil vous êtes pareil oui
oui oui oui c'est oui oui je crois que
là vous êtes bah écoutez ben on va on va
vous offrir comme galdine on va vous
offrir des vaccins
euh non non non non vous inquiétez pas
merci d'être là en tout cas c'est bien
je suis content que vous soyez là et
qu'on vous détende un peu parce que
c'est pas facile ce que vous vivez
racontez-nous ce qui s'est passé le 13
janvier samedi ouais bien écoutez je me
suis absenté à peu près 1h et15 ouais
j'ai rejoint ma sœur pour quelques
courses c'est un samedi soir je partais
de chez moi vers
18h30 et j'avais déjà a mis bien sû les
côtes parce qu'il faisait nuit mais
j'étais à s lieu d'imaginer mais sans
lieu de cette absence en plus ma sœur
m'avait demandé que j'aille chez elle à
Saint-Étienne C à presque plus de 20 km
de villeneu sur l'otte et j'ai dit non
non je je rentre parce que demain j'ai
une réunion c'était avec les Opex
et je rentre chez moi alors j' vu les
portes-fenêtres grande ouvertes les
volets tout j'ai compris les rideau qui
volit ma maison ne sucite pas la
première fois que ça vous a non c'est la
seconde fois parce qu'en 2012 il y av
encore mon mon époux ouais et je l'ai
amené à la maison des assauts entre 15h
et 17h et c'était le jour de mon
anniversaire un 26
septembre bien vous avez ils sont il y a
eu déjà et là ils ont volé euh il y
avait la télé l'ordinateur l'imprimante
euh je sais plus ce qu'il y avait encore
ah oui une belle monte que mon mari
avait offerte à sa seconde épouse
puisque j'avais épousé un homme veuve
deux fois ah oui oui je suis la 3è
j'étais la 3e j'ai conjuré le sort ah
oui mais bon c'est pas du tout c'est pas
tellement parce que malheureusement ces
deux épouses elles sont disparu deun
maladie la première en Cancer et la
seconde en plaque alors comment vous
avez découvert que vous et j'ai
découvert alors de suite quand je suis
arrivé j'ai eu j'ai j'ai été choqué et
je parle de mon deuxème cambriolage
d'accord oui les 27 médailles comment
vous avez découvert alors les médailles
je les ai pas tout de suite découverte
parce que elles étaient dans la
bibliothèque quand on rentre il y a elle
il y a une vitrine c'est une
bibliothèque
empire elle était c'était déjà dans un
coffret avec une vitrine il y avait les
médailles don ma Marie don don mon époux
c'était des médailles qui étaient de pas
de c'était surtout dans les associations
des opexc du Souvenir Français euh de
surtout ces médaillesl alors est-ce que
votre votre la police a peut mettre la
main sur les voleurs ou pas non pour
l'instant non alors euh aujourd'hui
j'aimerais savoir parce qu'on voulait
vous avoir vraiment aujourd'hui
rapidement pour retrouver les Médes m
parce que c'est vrai que ça ça vous
tient énormément à cœur euh quel est
votre message aujourd'hui à ceux qui
auraient volé les médailles simplement
j'aimerait il me rende ses médailles
surtout la Légion d'Honneur la croix de
guerre et la France libre puisqu'il
était engagé dans les Forces françaises
libres il a été pendant presque 5 ans il
a il a fait il a eu un beau très beau
parcours il a été décoré de la de la
Croix de guerre à Obenheim puisque c'est
là que dans un clocher c'était lui ou le
soldat allemand et c'est là que le
général brossé la décoré de la Croix de
guerre ben merci et la la France l
puisquil était délégué général puis il
était avec le général de Gaul voilà ah
ben il est là merci Lila merci merci mon
du cœur parce que Lila elle était en
pleur ça je euh voilà donc oui parce que
mon mari c'était ah oui c'était toutis
il était très investi pendant 30 années
il a donné des conférences dans les
collèges j'ai lycée pour lui c'était
c'était ça un passeur de mémoire
exceptionnel il a eu les Palmes
Académiques que normalement c'est dans
ça ça surtout c'est pour le monde
enseignant pas pour
le monde civil l là j'espère qu'on va
les retrouver merci beaucoup monsieur
Hanouna magnifique c'est vrai vraiment
vous êes très belle franchement pourtant
je trouve pas ah si si bah si je vous
confirme j'ai besoin ah oua B voilà
c'est vrai que je suis depuis 8 jours
plus de 8 jours j'ai l'impression que
bon je dors pas je suis fatiguée
allez il faut que je sois solide
exactement pour ça vous a fait du bien
de venir nous voir ah oui et ben merci
même si c'était un petit peu sur les
chapeaux de roues mais c'était très très
bien ça vous donne un S de décompression
rester sur Paris ce soir oui bien s je
vais à l'hôtel oui pris unhôtel bien sûr
bien sûr merci oui
non non il y a pas de je ne m'é parpille
pas merci il y a pas
de
[Applaudissements]
merci jeis pas du tout dans ce
dé voilà je suis pas du tout dans ce
délire
mais pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
vraiment pas du tout merci en tout cas
en train de se moquer hein non pas du
tout c'est vous c'est il se moque de
nous vous avez merci Lila d'avoir été
avec nous je vous fais des gros bisous
mais moi aussici passer une bonne soirée
ce soir merci infiniment merci vous êtes
à l'hôtel juste à côté là l'hôtel
l'Hôtel du Parc oui bah c'est où il y a
sieur chauffeur de
bus je connais pas bien paril bah il est
là-bas vous pouvez faire copine avec lui
bien tout honneur sympa vous nous direz
Disper pas se disperce
pas les médailles ex c'est les médailles
puis mémoire je voilà mais je veux aussi
vous changz les idées
peux pas je peux pas tant qu' a pas les
médailles pas vu mais médailles même si
les médailles reviennent c'est faut
retrouver ses
méillesch m mais pas une valeur
marchande rien du tout les
médailles me rendent les médailles mett
dans la boîte au
lett je vais pas les poursuivre parce
que c'est vrai que ça n'a pas de valeur
marchande c'est un geste c'est surtout
la croix de guerre r les
médaillesionhneur acheter une autre
ouais bah oui et la France libre je peux
en acheter je peux demander au général
brosser ouais brosser en acheter oui
brosser non d'accord merci général boss
merci général Bress pardon j'allais dire
fondation c'est
celuiation le poulet également de brise
merci Lila d'avoir été avec nous merci l
vous avez dit quoi non rien vous
inquiétez
pas ah oui voustez pas vousz pas merci l
d'avo attention parce que nous dans l'
on du bon fois gras oui ah c'est vrai il
a pas d' Bresque il y a un truc entre
vous hein ouais
ou c'est vrai ou pas Lila vrai on
s'adorit tout de suite on tout de suite
voilà le courant est passé ça vous
arrivera un jour
ouais ché merci Lila je vous fais un
avec plaisir merci monsieur